we're back everybody
now billy let's uh let's set this up for
a second you are
for anyone who doesn't know you are very
serious about about baseball
about the yankees yeah the yankees yeah
in particular it actually got me into uh
being a baseball player in high school
out of long island um
and then when i went to college in west
virginia a little bit got me uh
into stand-up comedy and theater i was
playing second base
and ameno first slow ground ball to
short which you hate because you know
you're gonna get dumped on a double play
and i'm there and i go to make the turn
and all i saw is this
uniform about right there and i got
dumped
up in here and as i was coming down
conan i saw a sign that said
auditions today
i better do that the comedy thing yeah
you hung out at you uh
you know of course george steinberg you
got to actually sit in the box
the world series later i started i met
joe torre i spoke at mickey mantle day
last year when they um they unveiled
mickey's memorial
and uh joe sadette was really great
anything we could do i said well
can i work out with a team once he's
yeah we're going to anaheim you're going
to be out there so i
worked out with them and then i started
calling joe torre on the phone he gave
me his numbers during the course of the
pennant drive
and became a thing like we were
superstitious i'd call them they'd win
i'd call them you know that kind of
thing and then i ended up
they invited me to the world series i'm
sitting in mr steinbrenner's box
and there's a weird combination the
great joe dimaggio
and henry kissinger and senuences and
i'm not sure why
do you like the game yes i do and
so now i had met mr kissinger about ten
years earlier on the concord flying to
london when i was doing saturday night
live
and i ended up sitting next to him the
plane is very small you've been on it
yes i've been on the concord yet so um
he's sitting next to me and it's very
tight
and i'm with henry kissinger and i'm
looking at him going what did the chicks
think about this guy he was like a big
ladies man he was great yeah
very big ladies with all due respect i
don't get it and
oh no one will hear that don't worry and
uh
may i say something to you he said sure
i've been thinking about this for a
while i want to say something to you
i said i said what so he goes you look
marvelous
[Laughter]
so now
now it's ten years later i'm in i'm in
steinbrenner's box it's the
sixth game of the world series and so
there he is and he's oh good to see you
again he said nice to see you mr happy
[Laughter]
he says i want him to get my wife honey
come here look who's here honey come
here
look who's here look billy joel say
hello
uh-huh so then the first game of the
series and the the yankees are losing
11-0 or something you know and he turns
to mr dimaggio who's this
you know this is the greatest hero you
know and and he says to him
yankees is thinking up the door and goes
hey joe suit up
uh-huh yeah and i said it's great seeing
you at yankee stadium
yeah yeah well nice to see you dr
kissing she said no i'm at the ballpark
call me hank
he actually got a sense of humor
a little bit well should we show this
thing uh we got right uh we uh
any setup we need for this we i have to
tell you your staff is great and you're
great we did this
so last minute yeah sorry you couldn't
make it that's all right
and
literally we finished playing at 2
30 this afternoon and here we are a
couple hours i haven't even seen it yet
because they edited this thing pretty
quickly and we did about an hour and
something so i i we have not seen we
have no idea what's happened but we'll
take a look at
our little trip to uh to yankee stadium
all right we're here in uh yankee
stadium uh billy crystal got us in thank
you billy you would now this is very
hard for you isn't you're a boston red
sox fan
i grew up in boston and when i was a kid
i used to watch uh
the red sox come here and play the
yankees and i was told as a kid and we
believed it
that if a red sox fan came to yankee
stadium they'd be murdered
yes and then we found out you'd actually
you don't have to be a red sox fan you
can just come here and anyone can be
murdered yeah
this is a handgun night here and there's
some other good
public beating night so i took tina
martinez's back
because he's got 14 home runs and like
way too many rbis
that's pretty good this is shem spat
yeah
this is pat kelly from the yankees up at
bat so
pat you're on national television all
right show us what you got
wanna i want a pitcher not a glass of
[Laughter]
[Applause]
water
here's your stream oh geez
into the seats antenna scenes that's
tommy tune
why do the hands hurt so incredibly when
you hit the ball
because you are very soft oh
i love him here's where i
actually show him what i'm made of i
think you look like marlena dientrich
after a crying episode
i always wanted to turn a double play so
maybe we'll get a chance to do that as
more fun continues
oh yeah wow did you see the kid from
boston dropped the ball
mr soft hand conan
catch the ball it was billy's fault what
it was right there
no you did it all wrong get those little
talk show hands
look at all the mail this is all i'm
guessing now
for daryl look at that daryl strawberry
daryl
[Music]
at this strawberry don't even need an
address to get to daryl strawberry
you just write down strawberry and it
gets here that's
impressive time cards all right oh
okay do they punch out after a game i
don't know
i notice you're telling me to do it yeah
go ahead you're the host i'm just a
guest
it's just someone who wants him to sign
his card that's nice that's cool
yeah you know i'm gonna get a real treat
for this kid i'm gonna sign it instead
that's gonna be a retreat for him so
that he'll be excited
once someone explains who i am now
everything daryl
this mariano four letters
yeah and look they're all in his
handwriting he writes from king's death
suspicious i do that that's the saddest
thing you can do look at this here
look this is going to get someone in
trouble
the yankees stole a shopping cart from
gristiti's market this is bad
if george finds out about this this
guy's traded whoever did this i think it
was george i think
i think george saw a way to save what is
this probably worth 38
38 bucks yeah this is interesting to
have a litter box in the middle of the
clubhouse
yeah it saves time actually
before the game yeah why go all the way
into the men's room when you got the box
yeah
can you help me with the pronunciation
that's a venereal disease i believe
master passport yeah you don't want to
get that no
how do you explain to your wife that you
got martial possible
this is a grown man wade bob he's 37 38
years old and yet
the upper left hand coin a little stuff
down here that's a cry for help if there
ever was one
team members only so let's go let's go
wow health food look see the players
stay in shape
sugar cookies you got your skippy this
is good hey look at this
gum
[Applause]
yeah that's a good one
that was a lot of fun very nice
great that was fun an honor on a uh
pretty cool you guys did a great job on
a real note though
uh on a real note you were really very
touched to be there i mean you've been
there before but you just
you first of all you played great but
you just were like a kid in a candy
store
oh isn't it the best it's one of the
best places in the world it's like this
huge
synagogue with grass you know it's like
the best place no i love that place i i
you know i grew up going there you know
my first game was 1956.
you love a team like i love this team
you know and you love the game and you
play a little bit but then you get you
know you saw you're out on that infield
and then
phil rizzuto played there holy cow and
oh come on i gotta tell you
it's unbelievable yeah yeah it was a uh
what was a good time for us too and
like i was saying today we don't have
access to many places so if you could
just get us into places from now on
where do you want to go uh i'd like a
remote in in france actually
just me and andy you take us to france
and we eat in the finest restaurants i
know some people
all right i'm looking forward to that
i've showed up on france's doorstep
before and then
go away no it's just going to be us
anyway oh no
andy andy
it's a happy ending it'll be okay
we'll take andy good yay we get to go to
france
all right uh billy crystal we can't
thank you enough and uh
best of luck with the movie i hear great
things about it and come on back some
time i will definitely billy crystal
everybody
wolfgang puck uncle madonna coming up
we'll be right back